sama mieux qu'un petit pas l'avoir parce
qu'en plus le veloster j'allais hériter
dans le fond de mon grand-oncle est
décédé éviter de tels vols c'est la
raison de vivre de l'organisme garage
529 garage 5 de 9 dans le fond c'est un
petit peu le meilleur des deux mondes
entre le système de burinage qu'on avait
avant et puis la communauté qui
s'organisent par exemple sur des groupes
facebook la plateforme est disponible
depuis la mi avril à montréal et le
principe est simple c'est une base de
données en ligne où chacun peut
enregistrer son vélo avec le numéro de
série les photos et de façon préventive
mais tous les détails du vélo en code
veulent le propriétaire déclenché une
alerte qui est acheminée à tous les
usagers de la plateforme pour qu'ils
ouvrent l'oeil les cyclistes peuvent
aussi se procurer des autocollants et
violable dans les postes de police et
chez certains détaillants cet
autocollant avec un numéro unique pour
faire en sorte que quelqu'un qui veut
acheter un vélo usagers vont pouvoir sur
sa tablette ou son téléphone et et j'ai
vérifié si ce vélo est volé ou s'il est
légitime
ce n'est pas la première fois que la
spvm tentent de freiner les vols de
vélos depuis 2011 le projet numéro
permettait d burini entre 1000 et 2000
vélos par annie mais cette fois est la
bonne selon le commandant gérard déjà de
1100 personnes se sont inscrites en
moins on s'attend à voir un dix mille
vélos par année dont 10 fois plus
efficace dix fois plus de gens qui ont
adhéré et puis un rythme semblable la
police de vancouver a obtenu après la
première année 30% de moins de votes de
vélo à montréal le vol de vélo est un
véritable fléau
le spvm reçoit 2000 son signalement par
année en moyenne pour ce type de crime
mais environ neuf personnes sur dix ne
rapporte pas les vols de vélos donc dans
les faits jusqu'à vingt mille vélos
seraient volés annuellement sur l'île de
montréal
ce qui est regrettable c'est que si les
gens se font voler leur vélo est à peu
près une personne sur dix qui n'en
rachètera pas et qui va peut-être
complètement arrêté de faire du vélo
d'autant plus qu'avec la pénurie le vélo
partout au québec il peut être difficile
de s'en procurer un nouveau ici
alexandrie bel et le radio canada
montréal